The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
So today's topic
is workforce planning.
And we have Professor
Nigel Wilson,
who is the father of
the Transit Lab here
at MIT and of this course.
He's sort of the master of
everything related to transit
and the applications
of transit data,
to operations
planning and study.
You may remember that we
divided the course into themes.
And so we already talked
about crew scheduling
in the context of
operations planning.
And now we're in the
strategy and policy theme.
So this lecture is on looking,
again, at proofs and planning,
but from a strategic
perspective.
I think that's probably--
NIGEL HM WILSON: That's great.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
--enough of an introduction.
Maybe you can provide--
NIGEL HM WILSON: Yeah.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
--a little more.
NIGEL HM WILSON:
Thank you, Gabriel.
It's good to see a fair
number of familiar faces
and some new ones
I don't know yet.
So I encourage you
all to jump in and ask
questions if I'm not making
things clear or if you disagree
or whatever.
But I'm delighted to
be here with you today.
So the work that I'm
going to be discussing
is work that I
haven't done recently.
It's about workforce planning.
And it was done with the MBTA.
Principally the results
I'll give are for the MBTA
as it existed 20-odd years ago.
But the issues are exactly
the same then as they are now.
In fact, I gave a summary of
this presentation to Brian
Shortsleeve and some of the
other people at the MBTA
a year and a half ago, or so.
And they were
thinking about maybe
they really should
[AUDIO OUT] --thing something
like this again.
So what I want to discuss
the problem in general
of the approach that
we've taken to this,
and then look at three
different levels of the problem.
One is the strategic
level, which
is the long-term
view, which fits
in with Gabriel's
statement about the theme
of this part of the
course being on strategy.
Then the tactical level,
which is shorter range.
And then the operational level,
which is really short range.
And these are all tightly
connected and interrelated,
as I hope I'll be able
to explain to you.
OK, so the challenge
that we have
in this part of the
operations planning
process, if you think
of it that way, is we
want to provide good service.
We've got hopefully a
decent operating plan
that we've developed
and want to make sure
that the service that's
delivered is reliable.
That requires decent equipment,
decent infrastructure, and also
a workforce that's
motivated and there
when you need them, which
is pretty much every day.
So the operations
plan you've all
been through this at
this stage in the course.
So you know what goes
into the operations plans.
So what comes out of
the operations plan
are a set of schedules,
timetables, runs, or duties
for operators to perform.
And that require a certain
amount of workforce or--
excuse me for using the term
"manpower," but it's sort
of the workforce that we need.
So if you don't have the
right level of workforce
available on a particular
day or at a particular time
on that day, then you've
got a problem potentially.
If you can buy work
on an overtime basis,
you can do that and at
least not drop any trips.
That's going to cost
you money though.
And you may not be able
to get the overtime, which
will, again, produce unreliable
service through dropped trips.
It may also, if some
workers in the workforce
feel that they can rely on
overtime, which gives them
a 50% premium rate, then maybe
you can take more absence time.
So there's a substitution
relationship here
between absence and overtime.
So if you rely more
heavily on overtime,
perhaps your absence
rate will go up.
That's not an outcome you want.
So you've got to be
very careful about that.
Certainly, if you
can't buy the overtime
and you don't have enough
people on the property
that particular day,
that particular time,
then you can drop trips
because you don't have anyone
to run the bus or
to run the train.
And that's a
problem because that
produces worse service
reliability, worse customer
satisfaction.
Politically, it's a very
negative [AUDIO OUT] as well.
And so workforce
planning is actually
a fairly critical piece of
getting from the operations
plan to good service on
the street or on the rails.
This is sort of a high
level view of what
the problem is, as I see it.
So on the left of
this chart, you
have the operator availability.
So that means the number
of drivers you have
available on a particular day.
That's affected by the
number of operators
you had available
the previous day.
If you hired people,
how many people
are coming on to
increase the supply?
What sort of attrition--
what sort of outflow
do you have in your workforce
from your previous time, day,
or time period?
What's the absence?
Because those guys
aren't going to be there.
Those people aren't going to
be there to deliver service.
And of course,
you have a roster,
so everyone typically works five
days and takes two days off.
And that rotates
among the workforce.
So this is the supply side,
in terms of the operator.
On the demand side, you
have the scheduled service,
which is a result of
your operating plan--
what you want to provide.
You have unscheduled
service additions.
And you potentially have
unscheduled service deletions.
For instance, if there's
a school vacation,
you will drop some
school trips--
trips which are primarily
there on high frequency
routes to provide
school service.
And these don't fit naturally
into the timetable process
because there's lot of overhead
in developing and timetable,
as I'm sure Gabriel
has explained to you.
So you'll just take those
trips off the table that day.
And those operators are
then available to provide
other service that you need and
to fill in for absent operators
those days.
So you've got the supply.
You've got the demand.
And so you're down here
looking at the availability
versus the supply of drivers.
I'll call them "drivers."
The technical jargon in the
industry is "operators."
In a perfect world, you'd
have an exact balance
between availability
and demand, and you
have no additional cost,
and you've got someone
to cover every trip.
That will never happen.
Why?
Because the operator
availability is stochastic.
It's uncertain.
You don't know what the absence
rate is going to be tomorrow.
With the best will in the
world, with the best models
in the world, you
don't know whether I'm
going to be feeling well
enough to work tomorrow.
So that's a problem.
And for instance,
in the MBTA, you
don't know if you going to
have a failure on the Red Line.
You're going to have to
bus parts of the Red Line
tomorrow at 8 o'clock
in the morning, OK.
So all of those uncertainties
affect this balance
between the
availability and demand.
So you'll never be here.
I mean, statistically,
it's virtually
certain you'll never be there.
You're either going to be over
here, where the availability is
less than the demand.
In that case, you have
additional time costs,
because you're going to have
to try and buy operators
to work that overtime.
And perhaps more seriously, you
have the risk of dropping trips
if you can't persuade
operators that they should
work the overtime that day.
Or you're over here,
where the availability
is greater than the demand.
In that case, you have
additional personnel costs
who aren't going to be used as
productively as you might like.
If they were going to
be used productively,
you'd have built them
into the operating plan.
So they're probably not going
to be used as productively
as your average operator.
So this is sort of one way
of looking at the framework.
We can think of, again, three
levels of planning here.
At the strategic level,
this is typically
looking at a one-year or even
longer than one year horizon.
So it's not strategic in
terms of infrastructure.
It's strategic in
terms of operations.
So that's how many
people will we
need in the driver workforce
over the next 12 months.
And how do we get
a hiring plan that
will give us the right number
of people throughout the year?
How do we allocate
our vacations?
Do we have a certain
vacation liability?
If I'm a 20-year employee of
the MBTA in the commons union,
I probably have about five weeks
vacation time over the year.
So I get my five weeks.
But the MBTA
management decisions
include when to provide
the vacation allocation.
So you may have an overall
life vacation liability
of 2,000 vacation weeks.
So the question of
the strategic level,
how do you allocate those 2,000
weeks of vacation liability
over the course of the year?
And there are good
ways of doing that.
And there are bad
I mean, if you give
vacation liability
when people don't want
to take vacations,
what's likely to happen?
Your absence rate's
going to increase.
So you really want to
give vacations when
people want to take vacations.
But you don't want to
give them so much vacation
when they want to take
vacation that it really
costs you a lot more money.
In that case, maybe
taking a higher absence
will be a better way
of dealing with that.
So there are really
important questions
on how to meet the
vacation liability.
And this is the timetable.
We've decided what
we need in terms
of finding decent service.
And then, at the
strategic level,
I'd also include
personnel policies.
So as I think you all
know, in many agencies,
including the MBTA,
you have a mix
of part-timers and full-timers.
In the MBTA, you have
Management Rights Act, which
I'm sure you've heard about.
Maybe Fred'll talk
about that next week.
It's a very interesting topic.
And Fred will make a meal
of it, I guarantee that.
So the MBTA management was given
these rights by the legislature
35 years ago, 36 years ago.
And so they cannot negotiate
about not using part-timers.
That's not part of the
contract negotiation.
That's a right they've
been given legally.
It's been challenged
in the courts.
It's been upheld.
And so they will
use part-timers.
They've decided to use
part-timers in a way
that I think is
very unproductive.
They use part-timers as
apprentice full-timers.
And so someone suffers
through perhaps five years
as a part-timer at
the MBTA in order
to reach nirvana of being
a full-timer at the MBTA.
Well, that's one
way of doing it.
But I'm not sure that's
the best way of doing it.
Perhaps what you're
doing is, you're
making these part-timers
suffer for five years,
if that's how long it takes
to get promoted from part-time
to full-timer status.
So they're sort of unhappy
for that five years,
because that's not
what they want.
And it's pretty miserable
working conditions.
They don't get full benefits.
And typically, they work a
6-hour day spread over 13
hours--
so covering the AM
peak and the PM peak.
And they're doing nothing
between the AM peak and PM
peak.
You hope they're not in bars.
But they're certainly
not doing anything
productive with the property.
So that's the way
the MBTA decides
to use the management
rights they
were given by the legislature.
I don't think that
was a good decision.
If you have separate
AM part-timers,
might you be able to
increase your workforce?
I think so.
You have people-- shop clerks
who don't really start work
until after the
AM peak who might
be very interested in
supplementing their shop clerk
job by having an
AM-peak driving job.
And similarly, in the
PM peak, you probably
can increase your
labor pool with people
who are not interested in a
full-time MBTA driver's job,
but they would be interested
in just a sort of a guaranteed,
3-hour piece of work every day.
So there are lots of different
ways of implementing this.
And I'm pretty sure the
MBTA didn't do it optimally.
So that's what I mean
by personnel policies.
So all of these are at
the strategic level.
At the tactical level, what
we're making decisions on
is the time horizon is
typically one timetable.
How many timetables does
the MBTA have per year?
AUDIENCE: Four.
NIGEL HM WILSON: Yeah, four.
So you're making
these decisions,
running up to each timetable--
the start of each
timetable period.
And the main decisions
are the staff.
And you've sort of got
your workforce fixed.
And you're deciding
how to allocate them
across depots or garages or rail
lines and by days of the week.
Those are the tactical-level
decisions you're making.
Those, it turns out, are
actually quite important.
If you make poor
decisions, then you're
going to be providing less
reliable service or more
expensive service than
you otherwise would.
And then at the final level,
your operational level,
is here we are 4
o'clock on a Thursday.
At 12 o'clock today--
so four hours ago--
the MBTA was deciding
when to ask each extra
board operator to show up
for work tomorrow if they didn't
have a guaranteed assignment.
OK?
So there are unexpected absences
that will occur tomorrow.
You don't know when
they're going to occur.
You don't know
whether it's going
to be an AM report or a PM
report or whatever it is.
And you have to make
the decision about when,
if you have five extra
board operators that
don't have an assignment,
because a known,
in advance absence, when
you want them to show up?
And that the daily report times
for unassigned, extra staff
is the operational-level
decision.
Any questions about
this, in terms
of strategic,
operational, tactical?
And I'm not talking here about
policies that may change--
absenteeism, for instance.
Fred will talk about
some of those next week
when he talks about
labor relations.
But I'm talking about sort of a
narrower piece of this puzzle.
Any questions on this?
Yes, Kenji?
AUDIENCE: [? Someone ?] become
the part-time operator--
NIGEL HM WILSON: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So are they
required any license or--
NIGEL HM WILSON: Oh, yes.
A commercial driver's
license is required for them.
But again, what I
was saying is, you
have choice about both who to
recruit into those positions--
do we want an AM part-timer
or a split-shift, full-day
part-timer who's
going to be unhappy
until they get their
full-time position at the MBTA
that they really want.
So yeah, sorry.
The other point I wanted
to make is that how
you select those people who
will get promoted to full-timer.
So you've decided,
through attrition
in the full-time ranks, you want
to promote some part-timers.
How do you make that promotion?
Do you promote based
strictly on seniority?
In other words, the first
one to become a part-timer
becomes the first one to be
promoted to a full-timer?
Probably not,
because you'd really
like people who are motivated,
who have a good absence record,
a good accident record.
So you'd like to use criteria in
that promotion, which are more
than just strict seniority.
And the MBTA, again,
has been, I would say,
not very effective in using
that balance between seniority,
which is an important issue--
you want to avoid favoritism and
discrimination in the promotion
process--
with having some
elements of performance
in the promotion
process, I would argue.
Did I answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
NIGEL HM WILSON: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I was
interested in the topic
because, yeah, we have a similar
culture for the station's
time--
NIGEL HM WILSON: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --in Japan.
But for the driver, they
require a very strict license--
NIGEL HM WILSON: Right.
AUDIENCE: --which takes
a long time to test.
So we don't have any
part-time drivers.
NIGEL HM WILSON: Right.
Right, yes.
And there are commercial
driver's licenses
required for the MBTA.
A bus driver or train driver has
to have a commercial driver's
license.
But it's not as a rigorous and
long period of qualification
as it is, I'm sure in JR-East.
That would be my guess, anyway.
Any other comments or questions?
OK.
OK, so let's look at this
as three levels of planning.
So strategic level-- we're
deciding the workforce size,
vacation allocation
over the year,
and hiring patterns over
the course of a year.
So by period of the
year, the input into this
includes absence hours.
If we know we typically
have more absence hours
in the winter because the
conditions are miserable--
you don't drive
in snow and ice--
and if you have observed
higher absence rates,
that's important in
making the right decisions
on the strategic level.
Required extra work.
If we know that we are going
to be bussing on the Braintree
branch of the Red Line
because of reconstruction,
then we'll build that into
our workforce planning thing.
So that's an example
of required extra work.
And attrition--
we do projections
about the number of
full-timers and part-timers
who will be retiring or leaving
the productive workforce
over the next year.
On the right-hand side, we
have input such as budget,
the service plan, the operations
plan, vacation liability--
how much vacation do we have
to provide in the next year--
work rules and policies
that we want to meet.
And what I'm showing
here is strategic level,
tactical level, and
operational level.
And what you'll see is
these downward arrows
from strategy to
tactics to operations,
and the upward
pointing arrows back
up the chain from operations
to tactical to strategic.
So let's explain
each of these arrows.
The downward arrows represent
constraints on your decisions.
So if you've made some
strategic-level decisions
on workforce size,
that limits what you
can do at the tactical level.
And that's this
downward arrow here.
Similarly, you make your
tactical-level decisions
at the beginning of
a timetable, that
limits what you can do
at the operational level.
These are these
downward-pointing arrows
between these boxes.
The upward pointing arrows
are the relationships
between that you need
to know about how
efficiently the operations
level is conducted
to make good decisions at the
higher levels of the planning
hierarchy.
So for instance, if you know
that overtime is virtually
impossible to get
from your workforce,
for whatever reason--
they may say,
I'm just not going to cooperate,
I'm not going to work,
or that could be bad or
good reasons for that--
then you need to
know that in order
to make the right decisions
at the tactical level.
And similarly, you need
to know that to make
the right decisions at
the strategic level.
So these are these
upward-pointing arrows here.
And the difference in the
inputs are just more detail.
So absence hours by
garage and by day of week
is important input into
the tactical level.
Absence hours by
garage and time of day
is important input into
the operational level, OK.
And you have work
rules and policies
as critical inputs
on all these levels.
So this is a slightly different
look at these relationships.
And I want to lead you
through this a little bit.
So this is our
strategic planning box
where we're deciding
workforce size.
What goes into this?
The unit costs--
how much does it
cost to provide a
platform hour, which
is an hour of driving
a bus, by an overtime
employee, a full-time employee,
and a part-time employee?
Those are very important,
basic cost units
that we need to have.
What's the budget, and
what are the work rules?
The work rules are important
because they tell us
how easy it will be
to do certain things.
And I'll give you an
example of that later on.
And of course, you have
the scheduled hours,
which comes out
of your operations
plan-- the timetable
requirements.
So given that you've made a
decision on the workforce size
at the strategic level,
on a particular day,
you may have an
amount of open work.
What do I mean by open work?
It's work that we
want to deliver,
but there's no one
obvious to provide it.
There's no one.
So we'll try and buy time
on an overtime basis.
So we're down here.
And if we're lucky,
the overtime--
there'll be someone
available who's
willing to work the
overtime for increased pay.
The negative side of that
is it increases the strain
on that employee who's working
more hours than he or she was
expecting to.
That may produce this
negative feedback on absence.
And I described it
previously as the trade-off
between how much do I have to
work to get to a certain target
income level?
Well, that's one way
of looking at it.
But the other way of looking at
it, which is equally realistic,
is if you're working harder,
that puts more stress
and strain on the body.
You're more likely to be absent.
Because there are two ways of
looking at it, which both raise
the concern about relying
heavily on overtime and what
that will do to absence.
Again, over here, if you
can't get the overtime,
you're going to
be dropping trips.
So reliability suffers.
Negative effect on service
reliability, service quality.
Presumably, that
will affect ridership
if it goes on long enough.
And that will affect
your operating plan,
because your ridership's down.
And so there's that
feedback, as well.
So this is sort of another way
of looking at the framework.
Now let's look at the strategic
level in terms of the planning
process.
What I've shown here is
a month, as was said--
four seasons in the MBTA.
Some agencies have more.
Some have less.
Winter, spring,
summer, and fall.
And let's have a hypothetical
workforce hiring scenario,
where we hire up at the
beginning of each timetable.
We sort of run
through the timetable.
And then we hire up
for the beginning
of the next timetable.
That's sort of the hypothetical.
That's not unusual.
But it's not a very
effective way of doing it.
And what I've tried to explain
here is why that is the case.
So the bottom bar in this
graph indicates the timetable
requirements.
So typically, the timetable
requirements for the operating
plan are pretty similar across
winter, spring, and fall,
and they're lower in the summer.
Why is that?
No schools, and
people on vacation,
so your demand is
generally down,
unless it's a very strong summer
tourist place, like Boston.
So that generally means that you
can reduce your operating plan
requirements in the summer.
That is a wonderful.
Why?
Because many drivers would like
to take vacation in the summer,
OK.
I mean, unless you're a serious
outdoor skier, ice skater,
whatever have you in
the winter, you probably
don't want to take
vacation in the winter
because your children
are still in school.
Parents want to go
on family vacations
when the weather is decent.
So this cross-hatched area
here is the vacation allocation
you've made to
fulfill your vacation
liability over the year.
And so what you
see here is we're
providing much more
vacation in the summer
than we are in the
winter, or even
in the spring and the autumn.
Why?
That's because our
demand is down,
but the vacation demand is up.
So that's a way of
minimizing absenteeism.
Makes our workforce
happy, it's a good thing.
So this gives us this
profile here about the number
of people we need to cover the
work and cover the vacations.
So the only thing we haven't
covered is the absence.
And we have to cover
the absence as well,
because those
people aren't there
to work that particular day.
So typically, if you did this--
you hire up at the beginning
of each timetable model
that I talked about--
what you would have is
something like this, in terms
of the extra board coverage--
sort of a constant
level throughout this,
except at the end.
And the end of the
timetable is higher
because people have
made changes and routes.
There's retraining.
There's training
of new operators.
So actually, your
required work is
greatest at the end of the
timetable in the last three
or four weeks.
So that's what this jump here
is, in terms of required work.
However, look at the supply.
Typically what
happens, is you have
attrition over the
course of the timetable.
And you have
increasing absenteeism
over the course
of the timetable.
Why?
Because at the beginning
of the timetable,
people have just
picked that work.
They sort of want to do it.
The grass is always greener.
They're sort of enthusiastic at
the beginning of the timetable.
They get out there,
and they realize
it wasn't all it's
cracked up to be.
And so when they're
not feeling up to it,
they're more likely to be absent
perhaps, as time wears along.
And then, towards
the end, they've
made their new selection of work
for the following timetable.
OK?
So what this suggests is you
have a surplus of operators
available at the
beginning of the timetable
and a significant
deficit of operators
at the end of a timetable.
So you sort of have one day
in the middle of a timetable,
which is perfect.
But otherwise, you're off.
You haven't got this good
balance between the operators
that you have available
and what you need.
So clearly doing workforce
hiring every month,
for instance, is one way
of dealing with this.
So you can reduce this hump
for training new operators
and spread it over the whole
period because, in round terms,
training for an operator
takes about a month
of on-the-road training.
And so you spread that over
the month, over the timetable.
So going to monthly hiring
makes a lot of sense.
And again, you
avoid these problems
having unassigned cover time.
What that means is
you've got people
who are being paid not to be
very productive in the garage.
You haven't got very, very
good things for them to do.
Because otherwise,
you'd have built it
into the operating plan.
And large amounts of
overtime and unreliability
at the end of the timetable.
And I don't know what
your experience is,
but in my experience,
that's exactly what you see.
At the end of a timetable,
service goes down the tubes,
because you get this imbalance
between higher absence
and higher requirements
for running
into the next timetable.
So you want to try
and avoid that.
OK.
So let's look at this from
a total cost perspective.
This is a very simple sketch.
I'll show you something more
realistic in a few minutes.
But this is the
conceptual part of this.
So on the x-axis--
and I apologize,
this is a typo--
that's number of extraboards.
The extraboard is
the cover list--
the people who are there
to cover absences or do
extra work that's required
not built into the timetable.
These are extraboards
or cover lists--
whatever.
And that should be the
number of drivers--
"extraboard operators," not
"extraboard operations."
And on the y-axis,
you have the cost.
So if you have a small number
of extraboard operators,
your fringe benefit
costs are low.
Your fixed fringe benefit
cost will increase
as you increase the number.
But you'll be relying
very heavily on overtime.
So you'll be having high
direct payment costs because
of the reliance on overtime.
And that gives you an
overall high cost solution
beyond some point where
you get a good balance
between the costs of overtime
and the cost of fixed fringe
benefits.
Then you'll get a sweet spot
you'll want to try and operate.
And you want to avoid
this, where you've
got so many
operators that you've
got a lot of people who
don't have a lot of work
to do on many days.
Yes, question?
Comment?
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
It's a question.
NIGEL HM WILSON: OK.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
I didn't quite
understand why monthly
hiring would reduce the time.
NIGEL HM WILSON: OK.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Can you explain that?
NIGEL HM WILSON: Yeah, yeah.
Sure.
OK, so-- sorry, yeah.
Thanks, Gabriel,
for reminding me.
It will take care of this hump
at the end of the timetable.
If there really is
an extra requirement
for work at the
end of a timetable,
you can hire up for
that a month before.
So if you think of this
as a sawtooth pattern, OK,
which is what it is--
you've got attrition,
and then you've
got a bulk hiring--
if you reduce the
periodicity of the saws--
the gaps-- you'll
reduce the integrated
imbalance between the
requirements and what you need.
So that's, in essence,
what's going on here.
Thanks.
Good question.
OK so this is sort of the
classic schema for analyzing
this problem, for modeling it.
So here on the x-axis, we
have number of scheduled runs.
This is for an organization
that sort of looks a lot a lot
like the MBTA.
And this histogram here is
the cumulative distribution
for number of absence days
in the previous period.
OK.
So now we're running into the
summer timetable for the MBTA.
So when the MBTA was doing
the analysis on this,
they were saying, well,
what level of absence
can we expect this
coming summer?
Well, we'll start by
looking at last summer.
That's probably a
fairly good proxy
for what we can
expect this summer.
And so the way they
would look at that
is look at the number
of absent operators
by day of week over the
full range of experiences
from last summer.
So on your best day last
summer for the MBTA--
these are hypothetical
numbers, but I want to give you
the flavor of this--
you had 16 absences.
16 drivers didn't show up for
work, for whatever reason.
On your worst day,
you had 60 operators
who didn't show up
for work that day.
So it's a tremendous range.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you explain how
the chart works a little bit
more?
NIGEL HM WILSON: Yeah.
OK, so yeah.
I'm trying to do a lot
in one chance here.
So this, if we
look at that, it's
the cumulative distribution
of absence days.
So this is the percent of
days which have absences less
than this number.
So it's a cumulative
distribution,
cumulative density function.
So what we're saying
here is that every day
had no more than 60
operators absent.
Every day had at least
16 operators absent.
And this is the
historical record
of absences over that period.
Now, the reason I've
drawn this line here
is to show you what the
extraboard sizing trade off is.
So we're looking at, say, 31
extraboard operators here.
If we have 31 extra board
operators and we assume
there's no absence in the
extraboard operators--
of course, there will be--
then we will be able to cover
all of the absences in area B
without paying any overtime.
But all of the absences
on days in area A,
we'll have to pay
overtime for, and we'll
have to deal with reliability
to drop trips on those days.
So the first point
I want to make
is this is a very simple
model, but it's very useful.
It provides a lot
of insight into how
you make these decisions.
The first point to
make is, my god,
that's a lot of variability--
from 16 to 60 operators
absent on different days
of the timetable.
So probably some of
that is systematic.
So some of them, probably you
have maybe a higher absence
on Mondays and Fridays than you
have on Tuesdays, Wednesdays,
and Thursdays.
So you probably want
to do this analysis
at the day-of-week level, OK.
Maybe you can group Tuesdays,
Wednesdays, Thursdays.
Maybe you can group
Mondays and Fridays.
But the principles are the same.
So there are different
ways of classifying days
to reduce the variance.
But you're basically going
to have this sort of trade
off between your [AUDIO OUT]
--terministic number
from this cumulative
density function,
cumulative distribution.
Is everyone
comfortable with this?
Because this is important.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm just
curious about--
so this is a broad spin on
public transportation here.
But I'm thinking of like
delivery companies might
be very similar.
NIGEL HM WILSON: Yes.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] consulted
by them for this type of work?
[INAUDIBLE]
NIGEL HM WILSON: I
don't personally,
but the problems
are very similar.
And the airlines have had
very similar problems.
I was on a trip,
not too long ago,
where I was delayed at
Logan Airport for an hour
because they had an
unexpected absence.
Their reserved crew
member happened
to live in Nashua,
New Hampshire, which
a lot of airline pilots
live in because it doesn't
have any taxes in that state.
And they had to drive
down, in the peak hour,
to get to the plane.
I was delayed for an hour.
So every industry has
the same sort of problem
when it's a transportation
industry, where
you don't have a shelf life.
It's not a production process.
It's a service.
And you have to deliver it at
that time, in that location.
So there are similar problems.
Again, it's not totally
dissimilar from staffing
in hospitals for nurses, for
doctors, everything like that.
So there's a whole
class of problems here
which are quite similar.
And I'm just presenting the
particular variant of this
for the transit industry.
Other questions or
comments on this?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is this
axis mislabeled here?
Should it [INAUDIBLE]
drivers, not scheduled runs?
NIGEL HM WILSON: Sorry.
[CHUCKLES]
No.
No, no-- it could be mislabeled.
What I'm trying to
say is, these are
the number of
scheduled operators
who are absent on that day.
That's what it really means, OK.
AUDIENCE: Runs for which
the scheduled operator--
NIGEL HM WILSON: Yeah.
So the analysis is the sort
of full day for a full-timer.
That's sort of the unit.
And you can label the
x-axis in different ways.
And this probably isn't
the best possible label.
But that's what
I'm getting at, OK.
Other questions or comments?
OK, so let's quickly look at
the strategic-level model here.
Decision variables--
are what we're
trying to decide is the
workforce size for each period.
And typically, as I
said, maybe the period
of a month, four weeks.
And vacation allocation for
each period and the vacation
allocation will typically be
over the course of a timetable.
So what's the average
number of vacation weeks
we want to provide in the
summer at a particular garage
or across the whole system?
We'll provide the same
number of vacation weeks
for all the bus
system in the MBTA.
And there's someone who's
covering the vacation--
just is covering the
different vacations
every week of the timetable.
So we have to have
the same number
throughout the timetable.
OK?
And the optimal hiring level--
so you get the right number
throughout the year.
That's sort of what we're
trying to achieve here.
And the objective is to
minimize the workforce cost,
which includes the cost
of the schedule runs,
the costs of the extraboard--
the people who are there
to cover the absences
and the extra work--
and the cost of overtime.
And you'll notice there
that I didn't include
costs of reliability
or unreliability,
because I'm including
that in the constraint.
I could have included in
the objective function.
But I'm including it
in the constraint,
just because it's
a little bit easier
to conceptualize it that way.
And we were doing this
work for the MBTA, who
kind of like to think of
overtime as a constraint.
Because overtime, as
you're probably aware,
gets a lot of attention in
the medial, in the press.
You know, "10% of
our budget is being
spent on overtime for drivers."
Those are headline
sorts of issues.
So the MBTA and transit
agency generally
are sensitive to the
level of overtime.
That's why I structured
this as a constraint,
rather than as a
multi-objective function--
[INAUDIBLE] multiple objectives.
Constraints we need to
meet-- vacation liability,
overtime service reliability,
part-time operator constraint--
sorry.
And any other policy
constraints that we want to
can be included in this
optimization problem.
And the reliability model that
we have is basically this.
So what this is saying
is we have open work.
What open work means is we
have work we want to do.
We don't have anyone who's
going to be willing to do it
without paying overtime.
That's what I mean by open work.
It's work that wasn't
a regularly scheduled
employee available to cover.
So overtime is available.
If an operator is available
and willing to work time,
you come down here.
And overtime is worked.
That may produce more absence.
May have those negative
feedback effects.
But at least you've delivered
the service that day.
If there's no operator
available or there's
no operator willing to work the
overtime, you drop the trips.
And you've got a reliability
problem on your hands.
Don't worry about the
individual points there.
But this is showing for the
bus network on the MBTA,
on the x-axis, the open work.
This is for a particular
timetable, system-wide
for the bus, and the
number of missed trip hours
that were incurred that day.
So each point here
represents a day of operation
on the MBTA bus system.
And so this particular day,
you had close to 300 hours
of open work.
And you dropped close
to 150 hours of service.
And if you do an OLS
regression on this,
this was the best fit we got.
So that means for every
100 hours of open work
at the time we did this
analysis that you wanted to get,
you were only able to get 72.
And you wound up dropping
28 hours of service.
That is pretty tough.
That's actually
really quite bad.
By comparison purposes,
I've done other work
in Montreal,
Ottawa, and Toronto,
which are pretty good, more or
less, east coast properties.
In Canada, they're
never more than 10%.
So there's something not
being done very efficiently
in the way the MBTA
covers their overtime.
And I think part
of this is probably
over-reliance on seniority,
again, and probably not
doing enough advance planning.
And what do I mean by relying
too heavily on seniority?
How many phone calls do you make
to the most senior operator who
might be available before
you say, he or she isn't
going to do this
work, and you go
to the next person on the list?
And how much advance
planning do you
do to make sure that you've
got a set of operators who
are really going to be available
if you have a need for them
at 9 o'clock tomorrow morning?
Those are the things that you
could do to try and reduce
this 28% missed trips to 5%
or 10% missed trips, which
would be a much better situation
for everyone concerned.
So this is the MBTA
case study again.
Bear in mind that this
was basically mid 1990s.
So it's 20 years ago.
But also, believe
me, nothing much
has changed in this
regard at the MBTA.
I'm not saying nothing's
changed in the MBTA
in any regard over
the last 20 years.
But certainly in this regard,
nothing much has changed.
And I think there are still
some of the same problems
that I'll talk about here
still in existence, which
is sad for me to admit
because, obviously, I
was trying to help them--
didn't succeed.
So at that point, the
part-time workforce
was sized to about 40% of
the full-time workforce.
That's a little bit
lower now, I believe.
There's a large variability
in required work hours.
So what do I mean by that?
The mean daily
absence and extra work
required-- this is apart
from the timetable.
So this is shuttling
service when
you get a line down
for signaling problem
or disabled train or whatever it
is, or fatality on the tracks.
The mean daily
absence and extra work
for the whole MBTA
bus system was
1,250 hours on a daily basis.
And the standard deviation
of that was 290 hours.
AUDIENCE: What percent
of that is total hours?
NIGEL HM WILSON: It's coming up.
I'm getting into it
in a few minutes.
But round figure's 10%.
AUDIENCE: Wow.
NIGEL HM WILSON:
It's pretty high.
That's not just absence.
It doesn't include extra work.
OK?
AUDIENCE: But it does
include sick leave, as well?
NIGEL HM WILSON: Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: Any kind of absence.
NIGEL HM WILSON: Yes.
Any sort of absence, exactly.
So it's not in any
sense absenteeism.
It's the amount
of extra work you
have to do beyond what's
the scheduled work,
the scheduled operating plan.
But anyway, it's quite large,
and it's very variable.
So it is highly stochastic.
Now, these figures
were from 1996.
And so the numbers will
have changed significantly
over the last 20 years.
But the relative
ratio of the numbers
in the different
columns and cells
has not changed significantly
in the last 20 years.
So what this is saying--
what we're showing here is the
driver cost per platform hour.
And so this includes
the wage rate
and benefits-- fixed and
variable fringe benefits.
So an hour of overtime worked
by a driver at that time
was around $30 an hour.
So sorry, the first
row is the wage rate.
The second row is the full cost.
So the difference here is the
benefits that are included,
and the productivity changes
between overtime, part-time,
and full-timers.
So for overtime, you get
a very small benefit load
because most of the benefits are
covered through their base job,
OK.
So the marginal cost
of overtime work
in terms of the benefit
load is quite small,
in the order of less than 10%--
or just about 10% of this.
Whereas for part-timers
and full-timers,
full-timers get somewhat
greater benefits.
So it's a significant increment.
So if you just scan
across here, this
gives you the straight,
direct comparison
between the cost of an hour of
work produced on an overtime
basis by a full-timer
or by a part-timer.
And in round terms,
you say, well,
if it's 40% part-timer,
60% full-timer, as the mix
of workforce, versus $32.72
for an overtime, it's a wash.
It's basically the same.
OK.
So strictly in terms of cost,
it doesn't really matter.
It matters a lot if you
have far too many people.
But it doesn't matter too
much in terms of the cost
if you have about
the right number
or slightly less
than that number.
If you have a lot
less than that number,
the short-run financial
costs won't change,
but you'll have
reliability problems
because you won't be
able to get the overtime.
However, what we really
should be looking at
is the marginal cost of the
last person on the cover list.
That's where we're making
the marginal decision about
whether we want to increase
the cover list by 1
or decrease it by 1 or
hold it where it is.
So if the last person
on the cover list
is being used 50% of
the time, then you're
making a trade off between
$32.72 for an overtime hour
versus $69.56 for the marginal
person on the cover list.
OK, so what a critical issue
is, in terms of any of you guys
doing analysis for
transit agency,
be it JR-East or the MBTA or
whatever it is, in this area,
you really want to look at what
the distribution of the costs
are of the cover list.
And a good proxy
for that is who's
picking the work
on the cover list.
If it's the most
senior operators who
are picking the work
on the cover list,
that means that's
pretty easy work.
If the senior operators are
not picking the cover list
and it's being left to the
junior people on the seniority
list, that means the senior
operators want to avoid it
because it's difficult work.
So that's a sort of
very simple shortcut--
do we have an oversized cover
list or an undersized cover
list?
Look at who's picking that
work on the cover list.
Is it very senior
operators or not?
Any questions on this?
AUDIENCE: So cover lists--
are those people who come in,
and they're sort of waiting
to go on a [INAUDIBLE]??
NIGEL HM WILSON: Yeah.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: They're not people
who are sitting at home,
waiting for a phone call.
NIGEL HM WILSON: No, no, no.
They're in the garage--
maybe playing cards
in the garage.
But they're in the garage,
and they're available.
AUDIENCE: OK.
NIGEL HM WILSON: OK.
OK, so I'm not going to
go through the model.
Again, I'm happy to give you
the papers and theses on this.
One of these theses was done
by Haris Koutsopoulos, who
many of you know quite well.
He's a senior faculty
member at Northeastern.
Another of the theses was
done by Yoram Shiftan,
who was entertaining me in
Israel just three days ago.
So there's some very good
work that's been done on this.
But the model that
came out of this--
I'm going to go show
you some results
and talk about what they mean.
What this is showing is,
under different scenarios,
the number of
full-time operators,
the number of part-time
operators that produce
the optimal solution,
the overtime as a percent
of the full cost--
the full cost, $96.4 million
in this case, per year.
Sorry, that's the regular
cost, regular time cost.
It's the overtime cost.
You add them up, and
you get the total cost--
$97.8 here.
And this is adding
different constraints.
So the base case, without any
constraints beyond vacation
or liability-- the things that
we've already talked about--
are that the cost of the
MBTA bus drivers should be--
these are 1996 dollars
again-- but $98 million.
And the reliability,
given 1.5% of the time
has to be worked on
overtime, and given
the way they manage their
overtime, which is not
very good, not
very well, they'll
be dropping about
0.4% of the trips--
4 trips out of every 1,000.
That was their existing
level of unreliability
in terms of dropping service.
So that's the base case numbers.
You could then add
different constraints.
If you add a constant
hiring constraint, which
means that we hire the same
number of operators every month
over the course
of the year and we
don't allow it to vary
from month to month,
what does that do?
It makes it easier for
the human resources folks.
the training people,
because they know what
their load is going
to be throughout the year.
And in fact, you can incorporate
that single constraint
with zero impact on the
budget or reliability.
So the solution is
exactly the same.
We've just juggled
vacation liability
between different periods.
OK?
If we wanted to have a
constant vacation as a policy
in the organization, we
add that as a constraint--
so the same month vacation
throughout the year--
then that would result in
about an almost $2 million
increase in the total cost
of the MBTA bus drivers.
We'd have less overtime.
And so our reliability
would improve
to dropping 2 trips
out of every 1,000,
rather than 4 trips
out of every 1,000.
And if we included in them
both the constant hiring
and vacation, which I
don't think you'd want to,
but this is just
to show what you
can do with this
sort of model, then
that would increase the budget
by an additional $1.5 million
a year.
And because you'd be
relying less on overtime,
you'd be having even
more reliable service.
So it gives the MBTA managers
a sense of the trade offs here,
but between the size of the
workforce optimally structured
over the course of the year
and reliability and overtime.
One different set
of results here.
This is showing,
OK, so what happens
if we change the level of
the overtime constraint?
So the base case here is
1.5% time as a constraint.
If we just eliminated the
overtime constraint completely
and said, just choose
the amount of overtime
that gives you the
minimal cost solution,
then your overtime costs would
be close to $12 million a year.
And that would enable you
to save about $1.3 million
per year on the
overall budget, because
of the relative costs of
overtime versus regular work.
However, your reliability would
go to hell in a hand basket.
And you'd be dropping 3
trips out of every 100--
3 hours of service
out of every 100.
And probably, this
is much better
than it would really
be if you did that.
Because this is not a
linear function, OK.
You're going to have
more and more trouble
covering those trips
and getting people
to agree to work overtime if
there's so much overtime being
asked of the workforce.
So this is a gross
underestimate.
But if you looked at 5%,
which is still pretty high,
then you'd save, in theory,
about $800,000 a year--
less than $1 million a year.
And your reliability would
decrease significantly
from dropping 4 trips
out of every 1,000
to dropping 120 trips
out of every 1,000--
no, 12-- from 4 to 12.
And then if you tighten
the overtime constraint
for whatever reason, then this
is what it would cost you.
It would cost you about half
a million dollars a year.
And again, you get some
improvement in reliability.
So these are the sort of
uses of the model that you
can use to inform management
decisions about how you
structure your hiring
process and training process
and extraboard size.
OK.
That's all I want to say
on the strategic level.
Any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Do you have a
sense of how difficult it is
or how costly it is to hire
additional, new drivers?
NIGEL HM WILSON: Yes.
Yes.
So there is a training period.
The MBTA, since
Fred was Secretary,
has had a lottery process for
selection of new employees.
And every agency,
including the MBTA,
has a pretty rigorous
testing procedure
you have to go through to get
to the point of being hired.
You then go through training,
the criminal records
check, all sorts of checks
before the training begins.
And then the training--
I'm trying to remember, I don't
have it on top of a head--
I think that the
total training is
in the order of six
weeks, which includes
getting your commercial
driver's licenses,
as we talked about earlier.
So you've got a certain amount
of advance planning in here.
You can't decide today, I
want to have more people
on the driver
workforce tomorrow.
It's not going to work.
So that's why you need to
have a strategic view of this.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Does this model
capture the behavioral feedback
loop?
NIGEL HM WILSON: It does not.
So that was separate work.
And we did look at that.
But it's not in the
results I presented.
Though, as I said,
Yoram Shiftan looked
at feedback effect between
if you provide more overtime,
what does that do to absence?
And what he found
was, it's variable.
For some operators, there
is a feedback effect.
But it's not as strong
as you might expect, OK.
So the MBTA management,
for instance,
was pretty convinced this
was really a serious issue.
It wasn't, in our analysis.
But there is a feedback effect.
It's not reflected in here.
Yeah, Scott.
AUDIENCE: Earlier,
you said you look
at the seniority of the
extraboards that are taking
work from the cover list.
NIGEL HM WILSON: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And you said
it's approximately
more than the work
that's desirable, right?
NIGEL HM WILSON: Yes.
AUDIENCE: The more senior
person takes the work
from the [INAUDIBLE]?
NIGEL HM WILSON: Yes, yes.
AUDIENCE: And I didn't quite
get the implication there
for the amount of
work, [INAUDIBLE]..
NIGEL HM WILSON: OK.
So yeah.
So if the most
senior operators--
who can pick anything--
are picking the extraboard,
that means you
don't have to work
very hard in the extraboard.
The extraboard is
probably too large.
OK.
That's the simple proxy.
Similarly, if the
most senior operators
are picking certain duties
in a garage in terms
of the types of shifts
and the days they work,
that's a good proxy for what's
easy, what's not so easy.
That's not to say
senior operators aren't
highly motivated.
They are.
But they also have their
own self-interest at heart.
They don't necessarily want to
be on a dangerous, difficult
route to operate.
Now, the problem here,
which Fred will get into I
think next week, in terms
of the way the US transit
industry operates-- there
are lots of problems.
But one of the problems in
terms of the way the US transit
industry operates, compared
with European industry,
is they rely very
heavily on seniority.
So what does that mean?
It means the least
capable drivers, who
are the people who
are new in the job
and haven't got a
lot of experience,
have the most
difficult assignments.
That's almost
certainly not optimal.
So it means you have
very poor drivers,
in terms of not
their capability,
but where they are on
the learning curve,
driving very difficult routes.
And the European
approach to this
is typically to have
a rotating roster, OK.
And again, in the
US transit industry,
one of the main benefits
of more seniority
for a particular individual
is you get to pick your work,
and you get to pick
your vacation time.
So if you get to 10
years at the MBTA,
perhaps you never have to
work weekends unless you
particularly want it,
which you often won't.
Whereas in most
European systems,
you're assigned to a
roster that rotates.
So you will all go through
the same experience
over the course of two months.
I don't know how
JR-East does it, Kenji.
AUDIENCE: Similar to Europe.
NIGEL HM WILSON:
Similar to Europe.
That's really the
dominant model elsewhere
that I'm familiar with.
There are trade offs in this.
So one of the trade
offs is that if you
use that as your main
motivation for keeping people
on the workforce--
you want to keep your
good operators working,
you don't have to replace them--
you can either pay a
wage rate incentive
for longevity, which is more
common in other agencies
around the world.
But it's not very
common in the US.
And so you progress from the
entry level wage in the MBTA
to the top level
in about two years.
OK, and that's not unusual
in the US transit industry.
And so because that is
such a minimal incentive
to hang around for
20 years, you want
to provide other incentives.
And so seniority, picking your
work, picking your vacation,
is the way the US transit
industry has followed this.
Gabriel, you were going
to make a comment.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ: It's
a half-comment, half-question.
NIGEL HM WILSON: Yeah.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
But when
we discussed crew
scheduling, we briefly
touched on rostering
and differences
between North American
and European practices.
NIGEL HM WILSON: Yes.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
And well, part of that
was that in European practice,
rostering is done sometimes
with some help of
alarm or helping
them to make the different
rosters as even as possible.
NIGEL HM WILSON: Right.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
And that
is slightly different
from picking them.
NIGEL HM WILSON: Yes.
GABRIEL SANCHEZ-MARTINEZ:
Right, so in North American,
these rosters are
formed by people,
but then they assemble the
rosters from crew schedules.
Is that correct?
NIGEL HM WILSON:
Well, the roster,
as I'm describing the roster,
is the rotation, if any,
of the work that's
done among individuals
over the course of a period,
maybe a timetable or two
months.
If you have a
rotating roster, that
means everyone in
this group goes
through the same set of
driving responsibilities
over the course of a two-month
period or a timetable.
In the US transit industry case,
you don't have any rotation.
You don't even have a roster.
So you're there, you do
the same trip every day
if you show up for work.
If you don't show up for
work, you don't do the duty.
So it's a trade off.
Personally-- maybe it's
my European roots--
I kind of tend to prefer a
European approach to this
than the US approach to this.
OK.
Let me quickly jump
into the tactical level.
So here, we're going
into the summer timetable
the MBTA in about
a month's time.
And so we'll be deciding.
We know how many drivers
we have on the property.
What we're deciding
now is when to assign
the work on a daily basis
and how many operators
to provide to Lynn versus Quincy
versus Arborway versus Cabot--
the different depots
in the system.
And again, so we're
allocating the extra staff,
these floaters, by garage
and by day of week.
And so we want to
know the absence level
on a more detailed basis here.
We have basically the same
sort of issues and concerns,
just at a more detailed
level of analysis.
And we can either use a
heuristic or optimization
for this.
And heuristics actually give
you a very good solution
because it's much simpler.
This is real data from the
MBTA, again, from 20 years ago.
So I'm not saying it's
exactly the same today.
But I would bet it's not
that different from now
from what it was then.
So this is a single MBTA garage.
This is the Cabot garage, which
is one of the biggest MBTA bus
garages.
And for that garage, this
shows the mean number
of open hours of work on a
daily basis over a timetable.
So on Mondays, 259 hours
was the mean number
of hours you had to
cover because you
didn't have someone available.
Standard deviation
of that was 36.
So that's quite variable.
Tuesday and Wednesday is
lower in terms of absences--
also quite variable.
Thursday and particularly
Friday is much higher and also
even more variable.
So following our
analysis principles,
the cumulative density
function, then you
would expect to want to
allocate your workforce,
your spare workforce,
reflecting the level of absence.
But no.
The MBTA was allocating their
extraboard exactly equally
across all weekdays--
20 extraboard operators on
Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday,
Thursday, Friday, Saturday--
Wednesday, Thursday,
Friday, lower levels
on Saturday and Sunday, but the
same percentage, independent
of the observed level
of difference in absence
or extra work required
on those days.
The model showed that if
you optimally reallocated
the same level of resources,
basically the same level down
here in terms of
operator days, you
provide more cover on
Fridays, on Mondays,
and weekends, and less coverage
on Tuesdays, Wednesdays,
and Thursdays, reflecting
the absence patterns.
That's optimizing the daily
level for a particular garage.
And at that point, they
weren't using part-timers.
They were using part-timers,
but the part-timers
were not on the extraboard
and not being used in quite
the same way that they are now.
And what you get out of this
is the expected overtime
hours over the whole
timetable, recognizing
the variability on
a particular day
is the expected
level of overtime
hours over the whole week is
140 hours versus 99 hours.
So you're saving about 25% to
30% of your overtime costs,
just by reallocating your
existing workforce more
effectively across
days of the week.
This is not rocket science.
This is actually
pretty easy to do.
I mean, you can get these
absence figures quite easily
and implement them.
So the tactical level findings
are significant variation,
absence, and required extra work
by garage and by day of week.
So what would you
expect by garage,
in terms of absence rates?
You might expect--
and you'd be right--
that the most difficult garages
would have the highest absence
rates.
Those are tough conditions.
So if you look at Cabot,
those are very tough routes.
And so when you do a
system-wide pick that
allows the operators to select
the garage they work at,
so the most senior
operators will avoid Cabot.
So it's the most
junior operators
that wind up at Cabot on
the most difficult routes.
Not a great surprise your
absence rate is higher at Cabot
than it is at Lynn or Quincy--
nice, comfortable
suburban garages.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How do you
define a difficult route?
What constitutes [INAUDIBLE]?
NIGEL HM WILSON: Oh, OK.
So there can be any
number of things--
very heavy traffic, danger of
accidents, danger of assault,
crime, danger of
altercations among customers,
passengers on the bus,
altercations with the driver.
So a number of things like that.
And so I'm not saying all
the routes in the Lynn garage
are great routes.
But compared with operating
in the inner city, which
is where the Cabot
routes typically serve,
there is a difference.
And certainly in Quincy,
there will be a big difference
as well.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So the workforce
would have differing levels
of information about which
route or which garage would
be more difficult [INAUDIBLE]?
NIGEL HM WILSON:
By word of mouth.
It's not a sort of a
conscious campaign.
The idea is basically,
you say, hey,
we've got a seniority system.
So you'll get to know other
operators of different depots,
word of mouth.
And you'll select, based
on what's available
when it gets to you of your
place in your seniority list,
where you want to work.
And often, it's based
on where you live.
You don't want to have to
commute from Lynn to Quincy
every day to do your work.
So it's a question of
proximity to where you live
and the ease, the comfort
level you'll have on the routes
and the conditions that
you'll be operating on.
OK?
And the policy of the
MBTA at this point
was to provide the same level
of cover at every garage.
Why?
Their argument that
they articulated to me--
and obviously, I discussed
this with them extensively--
they would not dispute the fact
that Cabot has a higher level
of absence than Quincy or Lynn.
They accept that.
That's not in dispute.
But their argument
would be, you're
rewarding the manager
of Cabot by giving
them more manpower if you
recognize the existing absence
level.
So they're concerned
about this feedback loop.
If you have more absence,
you get more manpower.
To me, that's a
completely backwards way
of thinking about this.
You need to have
incentives for the managers
to do a good job, hopefully.
But you shouldn't let
that be the motivation
for making bad
decisions about how
you use your resources,
which is basically
what's happening here.
And they were arguing the same
thing in terms of day of week,
as well.
So they were really
fighting that, that concept.
And I wasn't successful
in persuading them
that they should really
separate out the management
incentives from the efficiency
of the decisions they're
making.
OK.
All right.
The final level--
I've got a few minutes left--
is the operational level.
So again, we've gone from
the one-year planning horizon
to the timetable planning
horizon for three or four
months, now down
to the daily level.
OK.
So the objective here is
pretty much the same thing.
We're trying to minimize
the weighted sum of overtime
and missed trips.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm still at the
operational level here.
Yeah, no this is right, sorry.
So what we want to do here
is decide the report times
for any unassigned, extra
staff for the next day.
So as I said, at
12 o'clock today,
if there were five
operators who had not
been assigned work for tomorrow
at Cabot, then the MBTA
manager--
desk superintendent or whoever
you want to call him or her--
at Cabot will be
posting the report times
for those five people tomorrow.
You don't know what the
absence is going to be.
You didn't have any
known in advance
absence to give
them work to cover.
But you want them
to be available
so that when you do
get the absences, which
you don't know about, they
will be in a good position
to cover them.
And so this gets into the
most detailed level of this.
So it's not just a
question of having
the right number of drivers
available on a particular day.
It's a question of
having the right number
of available drivers at
every time of that day.
That's the problem
we're dealing with here.
So again, much more
uncertainty about how
the absence is at 9 o'clock
AM versus 5 o'clock PM.
And what this is showing
is this glorious concept.
It used to be called
"slop overtime."
The MBTA didn't like the
term "slop overtime,"
so it's now "excess overtime."
So you have regular
overtime, which is just,
you didn't have enough
personnel on the payroll.
And so you had to buy
overtime if you were
going to deliver the service.
Excess overtime is where, in
theory you have enough people
to cover the needs, but
they're not available
when you want them to be,
because you couldn't make
perfect decisions about when
they should show up to make
sure they're productive.
So here, I'm showing,
here, this is
time of day from 5:00 AM to
1:00 AM the next morning.
This shows the open run
profile, OK, like that.
Sorry, this is the open
run profile like this.
And this is the available cover
profile, based on your report
time decisions, like this.
And so what this shows is
that you have these periods
here and here and
here, where you
had more operators available
than you had work to cover.
And so that means that there
were other periods of the day
here and here and
here, where you
didn't have enough operators.
You had the right
number on the whole day,
you just didn't have them at
the right time in the day.
And it's not just you
made bad decisions,
it's that this is stochastic.
You can't make
perfect decisions.
So you've got to
expect there's going
to be some excess
overtime built in here.
And this is the
excess overtime curve.
And I will wrap this up in
four minutes, I promise.
I may not go through everything.
But I'll cover most
of what we want.
So this, on the x-axis,
is the available cover
minus the required cover.
So again, if it's
a perfect balance,
excess cover minus
required cover
is 0 because you
had a perfect fit.
But what that gives you
is the greatest number
of excess overtime hours.
Because unless you made
every decision perfectly,
you're going to have
excess overtime hours.
If you go way out here,
you had far more people
available than you needed.
So you shouldn't have
any access overtime,
even if you make
lousy decisions.
You put them out any
time, they'll be covered.
And you put them
out-- if you have
far fewer people available
than you require,
you'll be out here.
And you shouldn't have any
access overtime either,
because you don't
have to be very
good to make decisions which
will have these people be fully
employed.
OK.
So it's when you have
this exact balance,
you have to make every
decision perfectly
to avoid excess overtime.
And you're never
going to do that.
OK, so I've got
some results here,
which you can go
through on your own.
And I don't think I need
to cover this specifically.
But let me get to the
conclusion on this.
The analysis we did on
this level of the model
shows, because of the natural
peaking in work requirements,
that you have much more
service in the peak
than in the middle
of the day, the base,
it doesn't matter that
absence rates are actually
higher in the peak than they
are in the middle of the day.
Because your
decisions are driven
by the same underlying dynamic.
And so you just can make
good report time decisions,
based on the average absence
rate on that day at that depot.
So you don't have to go into
super detailed analysis, which
is good news.
And in fact, you can
wind up with having
a ranked list of report times
that the desk manager at Cabot
can just work off that
list for tomorrow,
based on the number
of unassigned cover
operators you have.
And it will always give you
a good solution, as opposed
to the desk manager making
decisions de novo, every day.
This is a very simple decision
support tool that can help.
So the operational
level findings--
significant improvements
are possible,
can reduce the overtime
and missed trips,
and a single set of report times
can be used across all weekdays
and seasons for each garage.
Separate ranked report times
for Saturdays and Sundays,
and constant absence
rates can be assumed
by hour of day and day of week.
Those are the main conclusions.
OK, sorry I raced
towards the end.
But I'm available.
I am retiring, as
Gabriel well knows,
at the end of the summer.
This is probably my last lecture
as a non-retired MIT faculty
member.
It's been fun doing it with you.
And I'm around.
And I will be around after
the end of the summer as well.
Just I won't be
being paid by MIT.
So if anyone wants to
discuss any of this
or go through any of
the background topics,
please feel free to come see me.
OK?
Thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]